good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today's
messages motivation is garbage over to
you Mel Robin we bought into this this
complete falsehood that at some point
you're going to have the courage at some
point you're going to have the
confidence and it's total bull frankly I
don't rely to swear it out okay it's
complete garbage and so there are so
many people in the world and you know
you may be watching this right now and
you have these incredible ideas and what
you think is missing is motivation and
that's not true because the way that our
minds are wired and the fact about human
beings is that we are not designed to do
things that are uncomfortable or scary
or difficult our brains are designed to
protect us from those things because our
brains are trying to keep us alive and
in order to change in order to build a
business in order to be the best parent
of a spouse to do all those things that
you know you want to do with your life
with your work with your dreams you're
going to have to do things that are
difficult uncertain or scary which sets
up this problem for all of us you're
never going to feel like it motivations
garbage you you only feel motivated to
do the things that are easy right what
do you think that is oh I know exactly
why that is because I've studied this so
much because for me one of the hardest
things to figure out was why is it so
hard to do the little things that would
improve my life and what I've come to
realize and what we'll talk a lot about
today is that the way that our minds are
designed is our minds are designed to
stop you at all costs from doing
anything that might hurt you
and the way that that that that this all
happens is it all starts with something
super subtle that none of us ever catch
and that is with this habit that all of
us have that nobody's talking about we
all have a habit of hesitating hmm
we have an idea you're sitting in a
meeting you have this incredible idea
and instead of just you know saying it
you stop and you hesitate now what none
of us realize is that when you hesitate
just that moment that micro moment that
small hesitation it sends a stress
signal to your brain it wakes your brain
up and your brain all of a sudden goes
oh wait a minute wait why is he
hesitating he didn't hesitate when he
put on his killer spiky sneakers he
didn't hesitate with the really cool
track pants he didn't hesitate with the
NASA tee shirt now he's hesitating to
talk something must be up so then your
brain goes to work to protect you it has
a million different ways to protect you
one of them is called the spotlight
effect it's a known phenomenon where
your brain magnifies risk Y to pull you
away from something that it perceives to
be a problem and so you can truly trace
every single problem or complaint in
your life to silence and hesitation
those are decisions and what I do and
what's changed my life is waking up and
realizing that motivation is garbage I'm
never going to feel like doing the
things that are tough or difficult or in
certain or scary or new so I need to
stop waiting until I feel like it and
number two I am one decision away from a
totally different marriage a totally
different life a totally different job a
totally different income a totally
different relationship with my kids
not like one decision I'm divorcing you
in in the marriage example but one
decision on you know you could be having
a conversation with your spouse and you
feel your emotions rise up and within a
tiny window those emotions can take over
and can impact how your marriage goes or
you can learn how to take control of
that micro moment and make a decision to
act in a way that actually shifts your
marriage your life comes down
own to your decisions and if you change
your decisions you will change
everything for another agree completely
that motivation is absolute garbage I've
seen motivation Lister meaning put on a
Tony Robbins CD and then wanted welcome
do amazing things amassed and I did it I
took action Tony my ear and I went out
and would do something that I was afraid
of join and I took action on it so I
know is it can work the challenge is you
know we don't have Tony Robbins chasing
around us all the time they lead us to
go and do something and that kind of
motivation is super short you know I
don't wake up every day and life is
amazing exciting way to go crisis this
is insane right and so that kind of
motivation comes bird and I think can't
be helpful but it's hard to keep a
consistent and practical managua basis
because even if I was a mess TV again
you're going to watch that video again
in Texas in fact if you watch the same
video over and over and over again the
first time it might be really motivated
Mike Schmitt you want to go will do
something and you want you to again any
attacks out there and third or fourth by
Soviets at 56789 ten times again I've
been destined for your honor that and
it's not moving anymore so that's why
it's really hard to keep that external
motivation going
I think what's much more practical this
community network consistent in my life
is one having an environment that is
designed to help you be more successful
so figure out what one word is - believe
I want to have an environment that makes
you believe in myself and the great
things that I'm trying to do on a daily
basis on a participation the how does
that you have a consistent basis the
people that you surround yourself with
the media that you consume the books
that you read your physical environment
and all that it all has an impact every
single day and the confidence that I've
gained over the past few years is how
much of this come out on the videos that
I've made
guys is in great part due to the videos
i watch the videos on my channel by
surrounding myself consistently with
successful people such as those
primitive people the way they act the
things they say their mindset the way
the interpret information the tiredest
reps are consistently come in over and
over and over again whether it's a
Michael Jordan or Mel Robin or an arms
with a girl or Bill Gates or a twenty
Robinson whoever it is you start to see
that these people think of certain way
and the more you see it not just what
they seem to do is not just do this step
but how they do it how they react the
question being around them
because I can't be around Steve Jobs
right in the past away I'm not going to
visit is great I can't be around him
anymore but I see in this video at least
it worked well for me and the more my
rounds last and more mixing water raised
up my feet the more it makes me feel
like I want to want to do bigger things
and it's allowed means that have older
goals to be more controversial to be
more myself to be you are as going to
change the your things the challenge be
more I keep doing it right and so I
think the environment you have encounter
self-awareness to know what their one
word is and then building environment
around it and habits and routines really
is important the second thing is
difficulty is I like to do trade-offs
around short-term fear and long-term
fear and so the training detection is
here the trick is capturing yourself
where you in a moment when you're
playing small when you're not doing the
big things you should be doing when
you're just super afraid and you
disguise it with some practical reasons
you convince yourself is it a logical
reason why you know I'm doing it we just
naturally play small and when somebody
asks you to do things
come on my youtube channel being yes it
will super like all that stupid
opportunity I think you have those
opportunities and then they just applies
with all these reasons right I'm not
ready you know I don't have a good
you know I don't have a gear out of a
webcam you know I don't have a
microphone like all these reasons why
they can't do it really digis afraid
that's the problem which is afraid but
if the passion is here they're not
passionate they're pushing it off with
practicality what is really feared and
so I try to catch that fear and then
replace it with longer terms bigger here
that's it so this one thing I'm afraid
of dealing versus 20 years old looking
back to my life you know 60 years of
regret
that's scary that's what I try to avoid
and tell the story about this girl in
Paris when I met where I wanted to ask
her out and I did too afraid to take a
picture and I didn't have to catch in
the picture I try but as it's french
scenery that I put up on my wall and my
university room because it was a
reminder not to let opportunities pass
by but the next time that I had an
opportunity to ask somebody else to say
yes to a business to would do whatever
the thing is I think in my head that be
cool to do exist in this new year comes
it
I'm mystic action and looking at that
poster every day reminded me so that's
when I had got out to the joint I start
up company couple months later versus
taking those jobs that I always wanted I
had that picture in my head saying this
business may not work out this is very
comparable to join me and I worked out
versus having this base job fun I always
want to paint $82,000 here but I didn't
want to look at the regret it is one a
little bit different Greta I could deal
with the failure I could deal with the
pain of not looking at us and giving 6
months to 12 months if it doesn't work
out but I know at least I know I should
have onset girl and friends Alice Solis
I know right I never since then I've
tried to make that same approach to
important issues in Malone I'll try to
ask myself yes I'm afraid it is my
contention I can touch the ceiling
I'm afraid in the moment but if I don't
do this am I going to regret this the
rest of my life is the interest yet and
don't
to do and then force yourself to do it
and it works police it looks to me
so the question day today is I'm curious
what do you think of automation how to
deal with this is a help you long term
short term I'm very curious about your
habits and your general foster
motivations leave it down the comments
below I'm excited to see what you have I
also want to give a quick show - smells
so low well thank you so much advocate
of a couple of my books here one word it
really means a lot to me and I hope you
enjoy the read so thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you know
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
decision-making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much you they like
the professor and you know the first
year I picked all my classes based on
workload and I picked everything a low
workload you know and pretty bored
didn't work very hard which is fine but
nothing was dynamic and nothing really
excited me and I thank goodness learn
that and so the second year I picked all
my classes by professor rating
regardless of the workload so every
class I had I had these dynamic amazing
incredible human beings passing on their
knowledge and you were excited to work
hard for them you know and so again what
the question is what if the filters were
using and so if you're only chasing the
mighty dollar then you will have jobs
that'll pay you a little more than the
last but are you enjoying yourself and I
talked to a guy recently who was in bad
shape like he really hates his life and
he's really depressed he doesn't know
what to do and so we were going through
all his old jobs you know and I said
give me a job that you've loved and he
had every single job he's chosen out of
college he picked because of the the
money and if something offered him more
somewhere else he took it you know
regardless and and and the amazing thing
is he plateaued because if you're only
chasing the result if you're only
chasing the thing that makes it easy
right then eventually you will get bored
or they'll get bored of you
right and you plateau in other words
chasing the old mighty dollar if that's
your only thing it eventually flattens
out whereas if you're chasing the thing
that excites you the human beings to be
around the work that excites you the
stuff that you know you know you can get
passionate about you know the the irony
is is you'll actually make way way more
right because you're excited and they
appreciate your excitement and they
reward your excitement and you're better
at your work because you want to work
harder and all of that stuff you don't
have to strain to work harder so
decision making is simply a matter of
filters you know and so I've made
decisions in my life
I would rather be happy than right I'd
rather do good then then get rich and
and so the decisions I make put me in
positions where when I leave any
engagement when I leave any meeting I
feel that I've contributed right rare
are the times anymore where you walk
arguing just think of the money just
think of the money think of the money
you know I because it doesn't feel nice
and and experience I have
I don't enjoy traveling to them and I
don't enjoy traveling home we're having
an amazing experience I am looking
forward to getting there and I'm excited
when I leave you know so it's just
decision make decision making is just a
matter of what filters you use and if
you're if you're good about keeping
those filters up and clear then then
make your decision I don't judge anybody
by how if they choose to use different
filters these are just the filters I
choose to live my life you know not
right or wrong just those are my
decisions you know that's my filter